oh my god are we have we started yeah
we're roll Oh guys we are here at Lee
Newton who's one of my favorite human
beings cuz I laughed so hard around the
human and we were just talking about um
lactose sensitivity and farting to me he
has some of the most incredible fart
stories I think you told me one on the
set of dirty 30
the first time you farted in front of
your boyfriend or something I have too
many first time I've part of it in front
of people her now I'm so candid and ok
with them I work with boys for so long
ago yeah always for so long yeah and I
like farting for the people be like and
they're just like no what am I getting
interested what is this a microphone now
at least it's a-ok with the boyfriend
and he like gets it but also at the same
time I do feel like he's like really
just over it like I'm over you being so
cool about this but it is such a thing
in relationships I think that's like the
threshold when you're like oh the first
time that you guys like sleep together
and then the first time you like fart in
front of each other and like you both
know it and like I have that moment I
think that's like the more intense part
of a guy's job like I've been living
with him for a while now so now it's
like we have one bathroom and there's
times you're just like oh no you're not
going to get through it all and then
there's like you have to have those
moments of like hey you got a gay yeah I
don't care if you have to be somewhere
five minutes get out and I get out and
you got to play music in the house real
loud right now put on a Michael Bay film
I like run water of all the time
guys are part of the job I know it's
awful des les yes wants to know hard
tacos are soft taco oh nice of issues
wanting this question brothers right um
Wow
this is it guys this is the day like
tacos I live for talk okay I love tacos
yep they're great like they're great at
all times
I also am now kicking into a burrito oh
I know
you're becoming a woman I'm becoming a
woman I do like those moments where
you're like miss burritos garbage I
didn't mean it
can you think any food is garbage and
it's like they're starving people about
you like this burritos garbage
I had a burrito opportunity at Chipotle
the other day and I told them and I was
like it's garbage
it's great like I was so upset that I
put forth the effort to eat it as garb
garbage reah
but there was a really great one on the
Brea that we went to it's like a weird
taco truck
um soft tacos I know yeah but like no
I'm with you and I like corn tortillas
like a texture of it me too
I can't hard taco that much hard talk
was for like for like Taco Bell and
stuff like that
our tacos difficult to eat dangerous
dangerous I've been cutting out so badly
cuz it also just like speaks to my
fervor of food that's my sport that I
get hurt at as an adult is feeling
antelco I will die choking I know that
oh that was like you're choking yeah
that's I mean those are the biggest
fears you have as an adult living alone
the fear of choking becomes real I'm
moving does it a lot and I feel like I
say arms up to him so much more than I
should
Oh anyone would say just like oh it's
the best to watch an adult man still
choking turns off good wait what is arms
up whoa it's like maximum was a runner
and she used to say like if we would go
what we were going like family jobs
sometimes when I was younger and if
you're something we did I was weird but
it should be like put your arms over
your head when you're completely out of
breath so that your body it stretches
out your lung and you're like like you
esophagus thing but it's just that's all
so much like this guy still thriving for
air and he's like like like maternal
instinct of like arms up I'm not but now
I say it with like such a lack of
concern it happens so frequently that
I'm just like arms up dude time's up
when I first moved in to an apartment by
myself in New York when I was living
there I did that's like when you really
realized the way you eat
and like you're forced to analyze it
fate like head-on because it's just you
and like there have been so many times
that I was like furiously eating chips
without even knowing it and I would
start choking and be like in my head
your thoughts move so quickly that I'm
like already imagining my funeral I've
been like why didn't she throw herself
against the chair to get anything to get
it out because uh yeah I've like choked
on chips by myself so many times but
it's terrifying and afterwards I I'll
never eat chips again but she's it
turning out though I choked on a lemon
drop having a lemon drop in like 15
years
oh yeah a lemon drop took me out unless
my brother gave me the Heimlich like
what a lemon drop like a drink like my
like a little lemon drop like you know
like those oh the candy things yeah yeah
brother be like well any like save my
life but now I'm like I can't like I
look at all do I look you out like you
really hyped like he Heimlich me out
like he was one of those like moments
where I was full-on choking well as a
brilliant child yeah you too give me the
Heimlich or that I always wonder am I
ever gonna be in a situation where I
will have to try and figure out if I'm
doing that cuz you get taught in school
but only like verbally taught without
ever doing it on someone anything yeah
you're like I'm breaking all these ribs
just mashing my fists against zero upper
body shame you're like that's just gonna
be it is like someone's gonna choke I'm
not gonna have I'm just gonna be like I
gave it my all for everything you put a
pterodactyl on top of your Christmas
tree no cuz I can't find their heart
define been and target been like check
for pterodactyl